[Music]
in Lohner Island news submitted by Steve
is mafia an isolated lighthouse in
Iceland is being hailed as the perfect
zombie apocolypse hideout where'd you go
off top of your head come on Irene it's
hard to present
India yeah you'll never be found
everyone all billion of them turn into
zombies it's impossible and let me tell
you why why please okay when I was a kid
my family loved watching scary movies my
parents the only thing my parents did
not allow me to watch as a child was
anything sexual sex scenes but I could
watch some dude just destroy someone's
brain and blow it up everywhere the most
violent things on the planet my paper
Americans [ __ ] exactly so Wow
my me my brother watched The Exorcist
once and I was I was [ __ ] terrifying
I was like five okay [ __ ] like really I
did not care that's it yes we watch all
these kind of possession films right the
oh man all this crazy stuff and I
remember being young and I was like to
my parents is like how come this only
happens to to white people like you like
black people don't get possessed Indian
people don't get possessed Chinese
people don't get possessed like what's
happening here and my dad it's like he's
like well if you're in India and you get
possessed the people will just beat you
dude we'll take the broom and beat the
[ __ ] out here and like that would be the
end of it you won't be possessing more
cuz everyday and buy a stranger's sold
of Indians killed the zombie zombie
apocalypse even though it's just like
you know obviously there's a lot of
people it's not like the cleanest place
yeah the first zombie infection that
happens you would just get jumped do you
would get jumped you will get [ __ ]
killed there would be may all be changed
patient zero because patient zero would
always die like new persons infected
we're taking them out
your dad's a doctor and he's like see
what's wrong with white people's they
use this [ __ ] holy water [ __ ] do you
beat that patient with a broomstick
every Indian mother would come out with
their wooden spoon later that they're
mixing whatever RINO rice and they just
come on beat the [ __ ] up or that you
would come home be like Oh mom this
person across the street we're scaring
me oh don't worry I'm going out that for
sure this is a spot that many people
feel is very ideal for where you gonna
get your groceries man how you gonna
make food you know how they do but you
but definitely zombies can't get here we
know they can't go on
maybe you got a farm you got across a
helicopter hey how you get up there how
you can't even grow vegetables no you
can't be a vegetarian don't disagree
there's a little bit of greenery there I
mean I guess you you could fish you have
a family there but there's no fire where
do you get five four vegetables like
seaweed or kelp or some so this place I
just showed you this was actually built
in 1939 so this is go or what it's only
accessible it's accessible is a
billionaire ty Marilee now by he'll have
had so before it was not like what so
back then they had to scale the cliffs
and like lay the grounds for the
lighthouse because materials up there
wait who was like haven't yet I'm gonna
over the house in 1930 now so this is in
Iceland and they basically wanted a
lighthouse out there okay for passing
ships fine maybe there's enough boat
start crashing into 1939 where boats are
probably a major form of transportation
yeah they're all crashing into that
little island and [ __ ] we have to do
something how far away from Iceland
Iceland is is Iceland right mainly it's
pretty close but it's not it's it's six
miles from the coast
someone has to haul Freight that baby
water transport wine yeah yeah
and it's also 120 foot high so that
workers
to climb 120 feet Thule just to bring
like one brick this is some [ __ ]
yep but you didn't live in 1939 man well
they're like like what do you mean the
[ __ ] we have to do this is some
[ __ ]
right imagine I imagine but I just
imagine like back in slave times I would
be complaining we be slaves yeah I feel
like it and you know what I'd be
drinking lemonade you know what I'd have
been like I feel sorry for that poor
fella
Holly CB would you be nicer but think
about back then that mentality I quit
I'm raised to think a certain thing so
you know for sure you know when they
were like oh how did how did the
pyramids get built or had its tell him
I'm like slaves bill knew like what do
you mean you know I was like if there
was no rules that yeah whatever their
own people yeah I was like did you just
you don't build it we kill you
no of course like how did they build it
that you know thanks bro
aliens yeah you know with the blowout
yeah he always he looks like a missing
member of Jersey Shore that guy but like
20 20 years too late he's like the crazy
uncle
yeah this is uncle Vito yeah uncle so
basically then this article is like
pretty cheeky but it's it's mostly about
how the [ __ ] they built this thing that
is now used like they still use it as a
lighthouse oh but but they have to get
there by helicopter now because people
don't wanna use both how do they get
electricity up as well back in the day
lighthouses were fired yeah yeah if I
what about nowadays do they have
electricity in now or my solar panels on
solar pendants I would actually be smart
if is ami apocalypse that's the only
thing you could rely on that would be
way too smart fit on that what is it is
a capacity of people is it a hotel I
gave to you this is an Airbnb now
[ __ ] madness 326 capacity what do you
expect me to say something like that
max capacity that British show her movie
it's about a real story about pirate
radio they had us they had an old it was
like a war war to like base out in the
ocean like that and it was like no man's
land and a bunch of hippies took it over
and they started broadcasting like radio
it's movie and then they made it like a
little country and then they [ __ ]
they were armed and stuff and then they
would like you know do some [ __ ]
pirate radio yeah Wow
when was this in the UK or some [ __ ]
it's like they had an old platform like
a world war 2 like army platform and
[ __ ] I looked up one wish it I won one
year I looked up the smallest the
country in the world and it's it's
called the carrion pit to pit carrion
islands I don't how to pronounce it hmm
but I think it's either near New Zealand
but there's like 40 people who live
there
yes Passport like I think I think in
theory it's part of the UK oh if someone
were trying to invade them and UK
Lacombe yeah okay but they're like
they're like number one export or like
stamps and homemade crafts but I'm
always I'm always like if I was born
what I think there was someone born
there like a couple years ago but it's
just like an interesting place I had why
would you stay there what would you buy
in there I don't know but macro man
necklaces I think they just trade with
will they just sell their stuff in New
Zealand Wow but it's it would be I don't
know why you would live there maybe
you're born there yeah but the first
thing I do is like I think often leave
record is like 40 people when I grew up
in a small town I was like I mean I I
think honestly legit legit really I
think it's under hundred people
afterwards what is everyone
hotter than [ __ ] I wouldn't want to but
everyone must be related oh [ __ ] I don't
care that's like watching Game of
Thrones am i good for them cobbler see
if she was my favorite one radio station
the radio station cuz I think they have
like one half and if they're uncle today
to devour one with Cersei and Jaime
Lannister hot you would want to multiply
yeah if Cersei was my sister I [ __ ] to
share her yeah yeah but Cersei is pretty
hair bald head I'm a surgeon see why you
like an attitude she's to me edge to me
yeah see but I found it would be the
most like one of the more proactive
characters because I still cook what's
her name okay I think I'm now blanking
our name because I've Elina no no the
chart target Denarius sheet for me when
I was walking show I was like this
girl's has third three three I don't
spoiler alert I just feel like she just
keeps getting lean on no she just
doesn't do anything and gets captured
and then like doesn't really do anything
and gets captured she's privileged we
need the dragon yeah yeah she's pretty
free at top when she first came out she
was tied to me and then yeah slowly she
just started like she gets busier [ __ ]
call Drogo stuff I was like this she's
gonna be badass but then she just
becomes basic yeah what's your name
again I just call her hot piece ass
[Laughter]
Khaleesi please I call sweetheart but
you know I don't know I wanted you to
really just kick some [ __ ] man you
satisfied with the end of the show it
was absolutely that okay I just say that
so far I'm so I'm season 8 episode 4
some [ __ ] yeah I'm pretty happy about it
yeah season 8 episode 4 I just survived
the long night with everyone and fought
my favorite ok wait till you get
like episodes 1 & 2 of season 8 but I
understood the necessity of it like the
rest of it I thought was okay and at the
end because I understand everything that
happened out behind the scenes I'm
forgiving but it's true it's not the
greatest thing in the world and it
doesn't do it justice because of her
great everything was before I see ya you
got a nd to me it was very much like
lost yeah like the first three seasons
of lost 2 is incredible television and
then the last whatever how many I can't
even remember cuz there's a thing I
agree with the outcomes I don't I don't
agree with the delivery of the outcome I
see yeah I see yeah stop spoiling out
with that yeah I'm not gonna say
anything right it's like under under
understanding the BTS of it you're like
okay I see why it has to be like this
yeah but if you didn't understand the
BTS of it then their life
I don't think it's I don't know what's
going on like production production
timeline writers leaving how many more
episodes but you get things the speed at
which things are happening is
unsatisfying yeah but I agree with the
choices so far yeah yeah oh yeah the
choices will
story-wise it makes sense right I think
so I I don't I don't the way it ended I
don't think so so you don't build the
build up you know I mean like you know I
can't say anything
I feel like sooner yeah come back come
back once you've I want to try to help
you with your marriage
whose stupid marriage I would have been
done already oh well you know what I'll
forgive you for not helping me on my
marriage if you just finished [ __ ]
watching the show manage the damn song
yeah that would help me in my marriage
I'll do it [ __ ]
[Music]